we're learning new details this morning
about a deadly collision between a semi
truck and a Greyhound bus on a busy New
Mexico highway at least seven people
were killed when the truck crossed the
median and slammed into the bus
yesterday more than 40 people were
injured the front of the bus was smashed
open in the top of the trailer peeled
off the crash happened on Interstate 40
in western New Mexico at least nine bus
passengers are hospitalized Don Dahler
is at the crash scene in Thoreau New
Mexico with first-hand accounts from
survivors Don good morning good morning
this is where it happened now
authorities removed the wreckage just a
short time ago but you can still see a
very large pile of debris behind me here
the bus was headed from st. Louis to Los
Angeles
it left Albuquerque yesterday afternoon
and had been on the road about two hours
when police say a semi headed on i-40
which is right over there in the
opposite direction
blue attire swerved across the median
and slammed head-on into the bus there
was one person hanging out the window
debris from the wreckage littered this
stretch of interstate 40 the
semi-trailer split open the truck's cab
upside down and in the middle the
shredded shell of the Greyhound bus its
front end completely ripped off
survivors and bystanders turned in to
first responders climbing ladders with
emergency crews to reach passengers
still trapped inside Chris Jones stopped
to help with the rescue it was
horrifying like I've never actually seen
in my life a bus like a ripped open
sardine can Rachael Cunningham was on
board the Greyhound bus she said she was
asleep when the crash happened and woke
up to a gaping hole in the buses
passenger side I was literally carrying
these people with the paramedics into
influences my experience what I've seen
today I mean some stuff that I only
thought I'd end up seeing on TV this is
the second deadly crash involving a bus
and a semi truck in New Mexico this
summer in July three people were killed
when a passenger bus rolled into
oncoming traffic Thursday's incident
shut down part of interstate 40 for
nearly eight hours as crews worked into
the night to clear the wreck as you can
imagine the scene down there is chaos so
it's gonna take investigators quite a
while to go through and actually
identify who was sitting where and who
are the drivers and who are the
passengers
officials say the truck driver is
expected to recover there will be a team
of investigators from the NTSB on-site
later today
Adriana Don thanks